Welcome to Market takes,
welcome and thank you so much for being with us.
No,
you could have been anywhere in the world right now,
but you're here with me and I appreciate that.
Listen,
we are unpacking today's nonfarm payrolls report A K A.
The Jobs Report today was a very interesting report that we got and I think
we've gotten a very interesting market reaction to the report and I think to a lot of
other things going on out there,
there's a lot of noise,
a lot of things,
you know,
contrasting indicators,
things that don't really match up.
We are here to break it down and explain what matters separate that signal from that noise and talk
about what's really going on in the market,
in the economy and what means what it means when we read through the numbers in this Jobs
report.
I'm Deon Rabon reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
Thank you all so much again for being with us.
We're going to talk about what this report said,
what today's Jobs report said,
how it compared to expectations and what we should take away from that.
We're going to talk about the trajectory,
the big term trajectory because it's not really about one number,
it's about how that number fits in with other numbers within the economy and other previous numbers.
We're going to talk about all that.
We are,
of course going to talk about the market reaction and analyze what that means.
We're going to explain the current market,
the current market focus on jobs and maybe the lack of focus on this particular
report.
And then of course,
we're going to talk about what comes next because there are some very interesting and very important
reports coming out next week in terms of what's going to happen next for the economy,
for the market,
the stock market,
all that good stuff coming up.
So without further ado,
let's talk about today,
the non farm payrolls report from April.
April's jobs report showed 253,000 jobs added last month.
That was well above the expectations which were for 180,000 jobs added.
So this was a surprising increase in terms of the number of jobs added.
Now,
the context here is that the April surprise contrasted with
revisions low for both February and March.
February and March were revised lower by 100 49,000 jobs.
So we beat the expectations by about 70,000 jobs,
but then the previous two months were revised lower by 150,000 jobs
almost.
Now.
That is a big deal because it slows the overall pace of jobs
added for the US economy over the last three months.
And it changes the picture completely in terms of what we're looking at on the jobs front.
The biggest piece of this report though,
I think when you read through the numbers and you really dig into the report,
the biggest number is the average hourly earnings number.
Now that increased to 4.4% year over year and 0.5% month
over month.
Those numbers by themselves don't mean anything.
But coming into this month,
we had 4.2% consistent average year over year hourly
earnings.
Now we've seen an increase,
average hourly earnings have increased and well,
well above expectations,
expectations was for them to stay at 0.3% month over month and 4.2% year over year.
We're above that.
And so average hourly earnings are increasing,
meaning workers are getting more money,
higher pay,
being able to demand bigger raises than they had been back in March.
And that's a big deal because wages,
we know lead to inflation and the Federal Reserve has been laser focused locked in on these
earnings numbers.
They say wages are too high.
Employees have too much,
are able to demand too much,
have too much leverage on their side because there are lots more job openings and there are unemployed
people.
Well,
this showing that those pressures have not abated even though some things have happened.
So you're going to want to keep your eye on what happens with inflation.
We've got a big report coming out next week.
I'm going to talk a little bit more about,
but wages have been lower than overall inflation has been pulling that number down.
Even after this report,
wages at 4.4% overall overall inflation was at 5%.
So we are still seeing wages below.
But now what you're seeing is overall inflation is coming down while wages which had been kind of
coming down and then holding well.
Now they're picking back up.
That makes a big difference,
especially because you're seeing the pace of overall jobs growth slow down.
It's also important to note another big developing story.
My man John Butters over at fact said he points out that corporate earnings as in net
profits,
those are starting to pick back up.
We saw corporate net earnings or I'm sorry,
excuse me,
net profit margins for big corporations S and P 500.
Those are picking back up again,
rising after six straight quarters of declining corporate profits as in net
profit margins as in just how much money corporations are able to make from every dollar of their sales
that's increasing again and rising and that's the biggest contributor to inflation.
So we're seeing all these developments that suggest that inflation while it had been coming down could
be picking back up.
Now,
let's talk about jobs a little bit.
I want to get into the trajectory that we talked about of that jobs growth,
put something up here on your screen to just show you what we're looking at overall in
terms of the jobs growth.
Now,
on the left side of your screen,
you see from 2013 to 2020 jobs rarely got above that
250,000 per month added number.
Right.
You see very rarely do they get above that line,
that 250 K line.
Now,
when you go to 2021 beyond up through today,
well,
they're pretty regularly above that 250 K line and even sometimes peaking,
peaking above that 750 K line.
But you see the trajectory over the last few months with a couple of outliers in there,
you see consistently moving down and moving lower and now we've seen with
March with February and March revised lower.
You're seeing now a consistent theme of job growth lower than it had been moving back
toward that trend that we have seen over 10 years before the pandemic and moving back
towards that lower growth.
So that just illustrating the overall trajectory of jobs growth and the way that we've
seen that move and it's moving toward a lower area of lower and decreased
job growth.
That's not a good thing.
That had been a good thing because job growth,
more hiring means higher wages means more inflation.
The fed has been working to keep that down.
However,
we could be getting to a point where we're seeing higher wages,
wages stay higher and pick back up while jobs growth,
the number of jobs added declines that points to stagflation potentially.
And that is potentially the worst possible outcome because it's where you have inflation high,
but the economy weak and those are just two things you don't want to coming together.
Let's look at the numbers a little bit.
Now,
the March number was revised lower to 165,000 jobs added from
236,000.
So that's down about 60 70,000.
In February,
it was revised down to 248,000 from 326,000.
All that's telling you is that we're seeing numbers revised down lower and you could
expect to see this.
April number revised lower as well.
Again,
we are still well above where we were the previous 10 years,
but moving in a worrisome direction and in fact,
the three month trend which had been at 345,000 jobs added over the
as an average over the last three months.
Well,
now that's 222,000 jobs added.
That is a significant difference between 345,000 jobs added 222,000 jobs added
as an average over the past three months.
That's a big step down and that's meaningful over the last six months,
we're at 290,000 jobs.
So over the six month period,
290,000,
over the three month period,
222,000,
you're just seeing this trend moving lower and slower and this is something I don't know.
The market is really looking at right now in terms of the trend and the trajectory.
Now,
I want to explain really quickly how revisions work.
a lot of folks don't understand what happens is the Bureau of Labor Statistics.
They have a household survey and an employer survey and they send surveys out to companies and they say,
how many people do you have working for you?
They call people and they say,
hey,
do you have a job?
Does everyone in your family have a job when they put the report out?
They do this over a couple of weeks during the middle of the month,
not everybody responds as those responses come in maybe later in the month,
maybe the next month,
they revise those previous months slower.
So what they've gotten is they've gotten new numbers for February and March and those numbers
show there was actually less hiring done because this is all based on averages.
This is based on assumptions.
The Bureau of Labor Statistics doesn't go to every single company in the United States and say how many people you got
working for you?
They don't call up every household,
they call up a sample and then they come up with an average.
Well,
those averages have changed based on the number of new survey responses that have come in.
And that's pointing to a more worrisome trend,
a lower slower trend of job growth than what we had seen on what we thought we had
seen earlier this year.
So a very clear trend of slowing jobs growth and that's worrisome for the overall economy.
Let's take a look at the market and talk about how the market reacted to it.
I want to put this here up on your screen and what you're seeing right now is live futures.
Now,
I wanted to talk first about crude oil because oil is really taken off exploding.
You see oil on Brent,
Brent and W T I both have about four,
a little over 4% gold down.
That's usually a sign of,
you know,
worries coming out of the market because people pile into gold and buy gold when they're worried about
things silver.
Another one of those things,
you're also seeing copper way up copper up almost 1% right now.
So overall a bullish day on the market when we turn to the stock market as well,
we are seeing the dow up about 1.5% the NASDAQ up 1.5% the S and P
500 also up,
almost 1.5%.
Want to give you a little bit more idea of what we're looking at the bigger picture and you see this
big jump before the market opened today,
you see the S and P 500 just really taken off.
Now,
some places where you might be seeing a little bit of the worry,
right.
A bit of the worry about this report,
the currency market,
look at the US dollar index.
Now,
we know when things get rough,
people pile into the safety of the US dollar and that's what's been happening lately as we've
seen the dollar move higher.
This was right around eight o'clock AM or 8 30.
When that jobs report number came out,
you see a big jump in the US dollar index.
We're coming off that a little bit but you just see that's one place where you might be seeing some of the worry
about this report coming into play so that just illustrating how the market is responding
right now.
Not a lot of worries.
Stock market,
I think is being moved on other factors.
We're seeing a big bounce back in some of those bank shares,
some of those regional bank stocks that got sold and hit really hard over the past few days.
Pac West is about 40% also,
Apple,
which is a huge part of the overall S and P 500 a big part of the NASDAQ
has a big day.
It's about 5% its best day so far in about four or five months
happening right now in terms of apple stock and again,
Apple,
a big part of the overall S and P 500 the NASDAQ.
So that I think is why we're seeing those movements in the stock market.
But right now we are seeing a risk on day and I think the market not really reacting to some of these
worries that are present and maybe a little bit buried in that jobs report just
seeing that overall 253 K number.
And people saying,
ok,
well,
let's focus on other things and take a look at that.
Listen,
let's take a step back and talk about why the market should be focused and why this jobs report matters.
The Fed wants to slow the pace of job growth.
It wants to slow down the pace of the overall economy so that people stop
spinning,
they stop going out and buying things.
They say,
you know,
what are too high.
I need to stay here at home,
not take out a home equity loan,
not borrow money,
not start a business,
not take on some more debt to,
to increase the size of my business because it's just too expensive.
And that's the goal.
They want to slow inflation down with their rate hikes by making rates higher,
that is not good for the stock market.
And so overall when you look at the jobs market,
the Fed wants it to slow down.
They want people to lose their jobs because that's the only way for inflation to come back down.
Meaningfully fed chair Jerome Powell.
Yesterday's press conference said something that I thought was very interesting,
especially for someone who's been in these economist circles who's surrounded by economists,
even though he may not be a trained economist himself.
He said I continue to think it's possible that this time is really different.
And I thought that was interesting because we know as investors,
as economists,
as folks who watch the market,
the most worrisome words in all of finance are it's different this time.
And Fed Chair Jerome Powell coming out and saying,
yeah,
I think it may be different this time.
What he meant is that maybe there doesn't have to be a painful long recession because of the
Fed's rate hiking cycle.
It may be different in a way other than what he thinks.
And what this jobs report today is suggesting is that it could be different in that
jobs start to decline.
The economy goes down and really hits a worrisome place,
but inflation may stay high.
The FED may have to keep raising rates to get inflation back down while the economy
starts to do worse and have worse outcomes for folks.
And that could be the way that it's different this time.
Again,
this is just one report,
one reported trend does not make,
but there are some worrisome trends in this report.
Also,
when we're looking at,
at the overall labor market.
We've seen the Jolt report.
The last couple of reports have shown a significant decrease in job openings and increase in
layoffs.
Overall businesses are cutting workers and they're not announcing as many job
openings.
This has been a consistent trend we've seen in the Jolts report,
the job opening and labor turnover survey.
We have seen also the Challenger job cuts report that came out.
We've seen a pick up a pronounced increase in job cuts as in layoffs as in
folks getting fired.
We have seen that from both of those reports again,
not at worrisome historical levels,
but we have seen a pick up from the very low levels that we had seen previously and we are starting to
enter a potential environment of higher stress and works numbers,
especially in the manufacturing construction sectors,
things like that fed manufacturing surveys from across the country.
Kansas City fed San Francisco,
fed New York fed,
they've all showed some of the worst numbers over the last three months that we've seen
since 2020 since mid 2020.
And those were some of the worst numbers that we've seen in history.
And we are seeing consistently those reports along with PM I S purchasing managers index
surveys of hiring managers and folks who run businesses and make big business
decisions saying things are getting worse and they're the worst.
They've been since mid 2020.
The manufacturing sector which is a small part of the US economy.
But an important part and important part of the economy has been showing a lot of stress and we
are starting to see some of those numbers.
Another place where we are seeing some stress is in the banks.
And I want to put something up here on your screen to just show you an illustration of that stress that
we are seeing in the banking sector.
And this is the senior loan officer opinion survey.
Basically how many banks are raising tightening lending standards?
What that means simply is banks are making it harder to lend,
they are raising the necessary criteria.
Whereas let's say the last survey was done in January.
So let's say in December,
they were saying,
ok,
you need a 700 credit score to borrow money.
Now they're saying you need 750.
Whereas previously in surveys,
they'd say,
ok,
well,
you need $100,000 in collateral.
Now they're saying you need $200,000 in collateral and you got to have this and you got to have that,
that you didn't have before because banks are getting worried this survey right here.
You see at the edge of your screen on the right.
It's already up at levels that are associated with recessions.
Every one of those dark patches or those gray patches you see on your screen or where we've had a recession.
And every time tightening of lending standards gets to the level that it's at right now.
And again,
this is before everything happened with Silicon Valley Bank with First Republic Bank.
This is before we are already at levels that are associated with and have been and have
been precursors to recession.
We are already there and we get the latest update to this survey on May eight next
week.
That's going to be highly watched.
Most people don't really pay that much attention to the senior loan officer survey.
I think they will be this month and that could be a market moving report.
So you're going to want to watch out for that.
But again,
we are already as you can see here on this chart at recession levels in
terms of banks,
tightening lending standards and that will likely increase when we get the latest numbers on
May 8th.
So this chart is just an illustration of the overall sentiment in terms of banks right
now that we are seeing in the economy,
another potentially bad sign for the future and for what could be coming on the
economy.
Um Listen,
we are going to wrap this up for market takes.
I thank everybody for being with us.
This was a very interesting and a very complex report and I think there's going to be a
lot more to come from it.
I think we're going to be talking about this report for the next couple of weeks if not throughout the month because
this points to a lot of things that could not be moving or that could be moving,
not in the way that the Federal Reserve wants.
And as we know,
central banks and the Federal Reserve are everything when it comes to investing and when
it comes to the economy.
So you're going to want to watch out for that.
What do we got next week on Monday?
We will be right here with you on market takes telling you what to look out for the coming week.
Next week I think is going to be a big week for the market.
So you want to tune in Monday morning,
10 AM for market takes.
And then on Wednesday we get the C P I inflation report,
the consumer price index report that's coming out Wednesday and we'll be with you again 10 AM Wednesday here on
Market takes.
I hope you'll be with us for that.
I am Deon Rabo reporter for the Wall Street Journal that's going to do it for market takes.
I hope you'll be back with us next time.